be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
the so what I want to do here is have a
discussion on how Franklin Richards made
Galactus is Harold while this story was
covered lightly in my video about
Franklin Richards publication history
what we're gonna do here is go more in
depth and what I'm hoping is that at the
end of all this you'll find this story
to be both beautifully written as well
as a spectacular display of just how
incredibly powerful Franklin Richards is
it's so it's no secret that Franklin
Richards is one of the most powerful
characters to have ever existed in
Marvel Comics with the power to alter
reality Franklin Richards is known by
most everyone from avid comic book
readers to non comic book readers while
Franklin Richards powers manifest
periodically over the course of his
initial publications following his
introduction in 1968
these early displays were usually minor
or else the byproduct of a villain using
Franklin for their own nefarious
purposes while future stories like
Fantastic Four issue number 245 expanded
on Franklin's powers by having him
subconsciously transform himself into an
adult as well as his creation of an
alternate universe following the
onslaught saga model found themselves
falling prey to a quagmire if Franklin
Richards had the power to manipulate
reality control all things within create
new realities and resurrect the dead
then why did these conflicts even exist
and couldn't Franklin Richards simply
phase a villain out of existence before
they could act and to take as a step
further
why does Franklin allow villains to
exist in the first place while various
answers could be offered regarding the
nature of humanity and comics and
Franklin's view of the world the fact
remains that these questions underscore
the inherent problem with a mutant that
can alter reality and so in order to
rectify this potential loophole in 2001
under the direction of Jeph Loeb Marvel
introduced the Abraxas event with the
destruction of Galactus from the
mainstream Marvel continuity the concept
of multiversal destruction manifested
itself in the form of Abraxas the
jumping from reality to reality and
destroying each version of Galactus the
event came to a head with a
confrontation between Abraxas and the
earth superheroes wildly outmatched and
with no real hope of survival Franklin
Richards resurrect Yuka lactis but
burned his powers out in the process and
so what we do now is pick up with
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four as he
takes steps to not only reinstate
Franklin's powers to alter reality
but incorporate them into a story that
took a deeper look at everyone in the
Fantastic Four and the stuff that they
would take to basically save the world
as so as we began what we find is that
the story initially picks up with the
young read Richard speaking with his
father Walter Daniel Richards is known
to be the father of read this story will
actually provide us with the most
in-depth information regarding his
character but furthermore I would like
you all to take particular notice of
this because the relationship between
a--the annual and read will be the basis
behind much of what happens in this
story and by extension the reason for
Franklin making Galactus is Harold the
conversation between the two provides us
with the idea that Nathaniel Richards
was a major influence and that for Reed
his father instilled in him the idea
that failure is a natural part of life
according to Nathaniel Richard's failure
helps us to grow and become something
more than what we are to refuse to even
try however is completely unacceptable
because it results in a waste of a
person's potential furthermore at a
young age Reid recognized that he was
vastly different from those around him
and that his intelligence set him apart
while Reed didn't immediately recognize
this his father had provided words of
comfort in telling read that his mind
would allow him to change the world and
to accomplish things that no one else
could and so the final piece of our
experience with Reed and his father is
the day that Nathaniel Richards left
while he doesn't tell Reed why he is
leaving and will actually find out later
in this story the only comfort to the
Nathaniel offers is that should read
ever truly meet him that he will always
be around and so at this point we
transition to the present with Jonathan
Hickman explanation that with Reed's
effort to solve the problem of
everything that his construction of a
multiversal bridge led him to a kind of
Nexus that has multiple versions of
himself referred to as the Council of
reeds
each of whom varied based on their own
individual realities as a couple of
examples and one reality
Reed Richards was a Silver Surfer and
another reality Reed Richards didn't
gain the ability to stretch his body and
instead became the Human Torch
now while Jonathan Hickman doesn't
explore every conceivable version of
Reed Richards that has ever existed what
he does do is plant the idea in our
minds of all the possibilities including
three versions of Reed each of whom
wield an infinity comment from their own
now as let's explain to us the goal of
the Council of reeds is to combine their
efforts to fix everything in the
multiverse and their efforts according
to the evidence presented to us is that
they've actually been quite successful
so far now taking Reed Richards on a
series of journeys the group travels to
earth eight nine zero one and this
reality Reed Richards is given to us as
a business tycoon on an earth similar to
our own but where Reed from the main
Marvel continuity focuses efforts on
stopping villains this version of Reed
Richards focuses efforts on solving the
problem of hunger starting with a 25
square mile patch of land this alternate
version of Reed Richards began growing
crops that could be used to feed the
poor and starving on the planet Earth
eventually his efforts led him to expand
this idea to other planets to other
worlds which could serve the sole
purpose of being a source of food that
can be provided to starving societies
across not only the universe but other
universes as well now the next journey
that Reed is taken on provides us with a
darker side of the council then a
reality designated as Earth 45 the
Doctor Doom in this timeline has
basically enacted a plan while the
intricacies of this plan aren't
explained to us the council takes this
version of dr. doom and plants a collar
around his neck now as is told the
purpose of this collar is to destroy
higher brain function effectively
turning this alternate reality version
of Doctor Doom into a vegetable and
taking him to a place called the hole
located beneath the council's base of
operations it's revealed to us that this
place houses a multitude of alternate
reality versions of dr. doom who have
basically been assigned the same fate
now as this explained dr. doom is a
villain who is perhaps the most
dangerous regardless of what universe
he's in due to the fact that his desire
for power is virtually unmatched and so
after weighing the options both good and
bad Rhee decides that joining the
council would provide him with the best
ability to do the most good however
during the commencement ceremony
these Celestials of Earth 4280 invade
the council now in this reality the
Celestials had basically become mad and
drunk with power believing themselves to
be gods they effectively forced the
reality's denizens to worship them
accordingly
and after encountering the version of
Reed Richards from this alternate
universe the Celestials effectively
stripped his mind and learned of the
council's existence and so seeking to
collect all of their artifacts and use
the Nexus as a way to expand their
control to other realities the
Celestials began killing off alternate
versions of Reed Richards
now while the alternate versions of Reed
were able to flee to their own realities
and bring back weapons to drive the
Celestials off during the conflict we
learn that in order to achieve their
goals to solve the problem of everything
these verses of Reed had basically all
given up their families and friends and
so refusing to accept this life Reed
decides to leave the council
from here we transition to Nathaniel
Richards and again this segment is
particularly important because this ties
directly into Franklin Richards making
Galactus is Harold and what we learn is
that Nathaniel Richards reason for
leaving read was that he was part of an
organization called the Brotherhood of
the Shield which had a long-standing
history on earth and was actually
designed to keep the planet safe from
various threats both internal and
external and so as part of this group
Nathaniel eventually came into contact
with a beam that possessed a vast amount
of energy
now while the beam was destroyed the
result was that a portion of this energy
was given to Nathaniel Richards which
actually teleported him into the future
gave him the ability to time travel and
actually drew all of the alternate
reality versions of himself to the same
place and so with this earth under
control of the time variant authority
which was a group designed to ensure
that time is not physically tampered
with the arrival of these variations of
Nathaniel from different realities and
times violated the very policy that the
time various authorities stood for and
so as a result an option was presented
to this group either all the versions of
Nathaniel Richards could simply be
killed or they could engage in a sort of
cat-and-mouse game where they would
basically kill each other and only one
would be allowed to stay alive and so
seeking to keep Reed out of harm's way
but refusing to engage in such a game
Nathaniel eventually left and went into
hiding by jumping from various realities
to other realities however all of this
was presumed to have come to a head when
he eventually realizes that as one of
the only two versions of himself left
that he would have to destroy his
counterpart or else face guaranteed
death and so eventually coming into
conflict Nathaniel Richards finds
himself victorious and after finishing
killing his former counterpart jumps
back into the timestream
now at this point we pick up with a
final act of this story where we
essentially get answers to almost all of
our questions but we also get to see
this entire situation coming into full
form when picking up with the birthday
party of a young Franklin Richards while
the events transpire as we would expect
with various fun and various games and
so on later that night a man appears in
the Baxter building and putting up a
force field that none of the Fantastic
Four can penetrate he enters the room of
Franklin Richards muttering something to
Franklin that isn't fully revealed and
then releasing him the words that were
spoken are revealed to us when we
learned that this man had simply said
rest and remember who you are and so as
the night progresses and once everyone
else has gone back to bed following the
departure of this man
Franklin's powers seem to have either
been reawakened or restored to him as
he's seen creating a universe inside of
his bedroom now as the story progresses
we pick up with the man having arrived
back in his own future words revealed
and this is actually in adult Franklin
Richards meeting with the Fanueil
Richards in this time Franklin reveals
that Nathanael himself is the reason for
not just the Council of Reed's but for
the nature of Reed Richards himself what
we're told is that when Nathaniel's
actions with the Brotherhood of the
shield resulted and all this alternate
reality versions being drawn to his
location as well as the following hunt
that resulted in all of their
destructions their deaths left Reed
Richards of all the other realities
fatherless this feeling of abandonment
left them wanting and in the desire to
find purpose they chose to join the
Council of Reed's leaving their friends
and family behind while Nathanael has
occasionally made appearances and Reed's
life these were usually short
appearances with Nathaniel rarely ever
acting as a father and so while he did
live and while Reed was not technically
an orphan his lack of involvement in
Reed's life amounted to the same thing
as a result while it's not outright told
us the sentiment as is expressed by
Franklin seems to be that Reed had
abandoned him at some point in the past
most likely due to his issues with
Nathaniel R furthermore we actually
joined Franklin's sister valaria as she
travels to the present to speak with
Susan storm while Valyria doesn't
possess any powers on par with Franklin
her abilities actually come in the form
of her intelligence which is on par with
both Reed and dr. doom
however her appearance to Susan is one
of warning and that as she explains
dark times are coming and the days will
be full of loss however when Susan feels
like she can't take anymore and actually
wants to give up she'll have to be
strong and keep the family together or
else everything will crumble and all
things will end and so transitioning
back to Franklin we find that valaria
joins him after visiting Susan and
although Jonathan Hickman is initially a
little ambiguous here the entire
situation appears to be an effort by
both Franklin and valaria to actually
change time and to alter some future
event and so as this existing reality
begins to collapse around them the to
jump into the timestream although we
don't know exactly where they're headed
so while there are other events that
transpire which don't really involve
Franklin Richards as some of these
involve the aftermath of Marvel's
annihilation event as well as the return
of the Inhumans and an attempted Kree
invasion of the planet Earth again while
a lot of these things aren't really part
of the events for our video what I do
want to do here is sidetrack for a
second at one point during this story
Galactus had become aware that his
presence would most likely be needed on
earth at some point in the future and so
as a result he provided Reed Richards
with a method to contact him once this
situation arises and while we'd
expresses a concern over when this may
be Galactus simply tells him that Reed
will know when this time comes what I'd
also like you to do is pay very
particular attention to what happens
next
while Galactus does not come out right
and say it his statement to read Richard
said they had quickly vacated the planet
Earth following his request to speak
with Reed was due to something Reed had
not noticed due to all of the events
taking place the Franklin's powers had
returned and for this reason Galactus is
actually scared of what Franklin
Richards is capable of now again this is
a very big moment in Marvel Comics and
especially for Franklin and Galactus and
the reason why is because over the
course of Galactus is publication
history very rarely have we ever seen
any indication that he actually fears
something but the fact that he's afraid
of what it is of Franklin Richards is
capable of says mountains about the kind
of power the Franklin Richards has and
so at this point we fast forward to the
present with Reed having summoned
Galactus due to the Kree attacking the
planet Earth now again this is not
necessarily a wildly important part of
the story the only reason why I really
bring this up is because it gives us a
basis for why Galactus is being summoned
in the first place while we believe that
this is what Galactus was referring to
when he had given Reed the power to
summon him Galactus states that this is
not what he was referring to
however after destroying most of the
Kree Armada and sending the rest fleeing
for their lives the reason for Galactus
providing Reed with the means to summon
him is revealed when the mad Celestials
arrive the having previously discovered
a way to enter this reality following
their destruction of the Council of
Reed's as well as the Nexus their
intention seems to be the wholesale
conquering of this reality
now while calacas is able to hold his
own and even destroy one of them
the remaining three Celestials realize
in the thought that they face merged
into a singular being and together
overpower Galactus presumably killing
him now while the arrival of Nathaniel
Richards along with various weapons
developed by Richard Saar able to force
the Celestials to revert back to their
individual selves their attention is now
turned to the Fantastic Four
while the group is bombarded with a
series of attacks Valyria pleads with
Franklin to take action to which point
he replies that he was told not to do
anything yet now while this does take
the rest of the Fantastic Four by
surprise it actually draws her curiosity
the fact remains that as the attacks
continue and with all hope seeming lost
the group is met with the arrival of
Franklin Richards and valaria Richards
from the future
now after analyzing future Franklin and
these Celestials established for us as
the reader the power the Franklin
Richards possesses recognizing him as in
effect a cosmic entity within the Marvel
Universe on par with the most powerful
beings in existence Franklin immediately
wish them away to another part of the
galaxy
speaking directly with his younger self
we learned that future Franklin had been
instructing his younger self on how to
harness his power and more importantly
to store his powers up at this point the
Celestials make the return to the planet
Earth engaging in a battle with these
Celestials themselves our attention is
actually drawn to both in fania Richards
as he speaks to Reed Richards and
Franklin Richards while he's fighting
and what Nathaniel tells us is that
during his life he has travelled to this
moment countless times and every
instance Reed is always joined the
counsel that he's always forsaken his
family and always died when the mad
Celestials invaded each time Nathaniel
had tried to intervene manipulate or in
some capacity keep this from happening
but each time Reed Richards always ended
up dying however where Nathaniel was
unable to solve the riddle
Franklin was real lights under was in
his father's nature to desire to solve
the riddle of everything do
way to prevent his death was to allow
the situation to play out as it was
supposed to and then intervene at the
right moment to ensure Reed Richards
survival and so using the power
collected from his younger self
Franklin revived Galactus and bestowed
him with new energies calling Galactus
forward as his Herald combining alive is
his vast powers with Franklin's Galactus
is able to easily and swiftly destroy
the Celestials entirely and while the
belief is a prank that had actually died
in the conflict the aftermath reveals
him to be alive and well and so
following this these story transitions
to the epilogue where we learn that with
Reid's understanding of how far
Franklin's power stretches rather than
putting mental blocks in place keeping
him from using them Reed begins to Train
Franklin on how to use his abilities in
a more intricate way but that being said
we're gonna go ahead and read this video
to an end hope you guys enjoyed it and I
will catch you guys later
peace